quisiera comenzar preguntándole si puede
china aportar a la Paz en medio oriente
bien gracias por la invitación
definitivamente china Tiene bastantes
intereses en el medio oriente y más allá
de su rol de mediador que por supuesto
quiere cristalizar el interés de china
en medio oriente también tiene un tinte
económico y comercial Yo pienso que
cualquier tema que nosotros queramos
analizar sobre china necesariamente debe
atravesar el lente de la Beltrán que es
esta proyecto o esta iniciativa china
donde quiere literalmente conectar al
país de diferentes maneras ya sea a
través de los océanos o sea de manera
ferroviaria o sea de manera terrestre
por supuesto el el objetivo de chillín
Pin de tener una presencia en medio
oriente es calmar la zona porque en la
medida en que haya mucha más calma en
este sentido alcanzar Ojalá alguna
conciliación o facilidad de alguna
manera la mediación en en esa zona del
mundo se va a traducir necesariamente
una mayor estabilidad jurídica mayor
estabilidad en las relaciones privadas y
por lo tanto mayor la posibilidad de
alcanzar los objetivos a través de esta
esta propuesta Que obviamente une
conecta y generaría muchos negocios y
muchos se satisfarían muchos intereses
para los actores privados que están allá
y que tienen este gran interés sin duda
continuamos Cómo ha sido históricamente
los lazos entre China y Palestina
básicamente el más allá del lazo que
quiera trazar sin con Palestina el
objetivo sin duda es tener dos caras de
una sola moneda alcanzar por un lado una
certeza en términos de seguridad y
defensa en una zona tradicionalmente
movida o una zona tradicionalmente roja
por estas fuertes diferencias históricas
y de otro lado el mensaje que quieren
ver si Pink es esta propuesta más que
todo de Concepción de desarrollo que
maneja China y en este sentido esta
visión o esta propuesta de desarrollo no
tiene por qué excluir al Medio Oriente
básicamente Más allá de mirar las
relaciones entre China y y el territorio
palestino esta medida china responde
mucho a esta jugada y la jugada es como
asiático con muchísimo poder Y
muchísimas capacidades desde que ingresó
a la omc en el año 2001 puede irradiar
Este modelo de desarrollo con un tinte
claramente
chino y ello no excluye De ninguna
manera al Medio Oriente creo que el
mensaje hay que verlo así porque
precisamente los países que han decidido
adherirse a esta propuesta que es la
berlan Road iniciar lo que quieren es
generar estos enlaces y generar estas
Buenas relaciones Obviamente que China
tiene toda la disposición no puede
quedar excluido